congratulations you guys on the nominees
Thank You being here as nominees in a
while that's it's an honor it's a sell
it no matter what happens tonight I'm
celebration you're so Beyonce
congratulations because first of all you
all have your hair which is incredible
and very important at this point to pay
for this but yes it's true again it's
been an incredible time for you guys
coming back together you know the
chemistry is alive we can always tell
when Bears get back together is for the
money you can tell with you guys that's
different this time you know the Vegas
residency getting out there doing the
thing with chance the other night 20th
anniversary so much exciting stuff going
on how's it feel this time around I mean
it just it's incredible I mean look we
we've been together for 26 years and you
know it's it's like a family you know
and it never gets old for us and we're
just enjoying every single day and
everything that's coming our way
I think about that Eddie you guys DubLi
chance you know I think about the 20th
anniversary and how that song has kind
of it means so much to people that song
is really lasted did you know that that
song was gonna have that effect when you
when you made it it would be that way
you huh very good we hug show but you
know we we love music we're music fans
we put a lot of work and passion and
heart into what we do and I think that
by us being nominated 26 years into the
game it's showing and paying dividends
and we're just honored and it's a
celebration it's a privilege just keep
growing and keep working hard keep
creating and believe residence oh I'm
sorry no no no no no no residency coming
to a close what else is coming for you
guys we've got a big night right now
rehearsing and DNA work comes up in May
and they come to the states and July to
September and we try to hit the rest of
the world you recently said that your
dream would be to tour with NSYNC and
Spice Girls to get everybody back to
music
we thought that would be a huge stadium
or a big festival yeah you are festival
I mean yes street fest boy PSP fest mini
always pop loose a right to camera who
are you dying to collaborate still and
make a plea right to them hey Bruno dude
we go way back play your poker at my
hand let's do something on the table
he's pregnant if he's very good actually
- we rock some doo-wop with you brother
thank you all this are huge fans which
one he was the best poker player depends
on you know you were face which it yes
yes they do yeah yes they do it's gonna
be amazing - might be to be here you
know to be able to be nominated at this
point and have so much to look forward
to we wish you the best Cosmo you so
much career achieved yes thank you guys
so much
[Music]
[Applause]